بالفعل اليوم تعد سفينه امانه السفير
المدنيه التجاريه التابعه للحكومه
السعوديه كان على متنها 20 مواطن السعودي
و1,86 مواطن اجنبي باختلاف جنسيات وكان
على متن هذه السفينه كذلك
155 شخص من موظفي من منظمه الامم المتحده
وكذلك 65 مواطن ايراني دقائق محدوده
وقد تتم الانتهاء من عمليات الانزال بشكل
كبير سوف تنقلهم هذه الحافلات وهي عددها
47 حافله تم تخصيصها من قبل السلطات
السعوديه لنقل كافه الرعايه من الذين تم
انزالهم من سفينه امانه الى مساكنهم هنا
بجده قبل الخوف في تفاصيل اخرى معي الان
الاستاذ الدكتوره نتعرف عليك اولا دكتوره
غاده مطر ناشطه بحقوق الانسان والمراه
سودانيه وافتخر
ومن هنا نحن بنقول انه نحن سوف نعود وحتما
نعود للكوخ الموشح بالورود سنعود يا
سوداننا وسنعود اجمل والشكر هنا للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وخادم الحرمين الشريفين
يعني استضافته لينا وارسال الباخره وجينا
من بورسودان وقبلها من مدني ومن الخرطوم
منا ديارنا والذين اخرجوا من ديارهم بغير
حقه الا ان يقولوا ربنا الله سنتمنى
العوده القريبه باذن الله وشكرا لكم شكرا
الان سوف ننتقل للاحدى او سوف نصعد الى
احدى الحافلات التي تم تخصيصها من قبل
سلطه السعوديه لنقل كافه الرعايه من هنا
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده الى
المساكن المخصصه لهم هذه الحافلات على متن
كل حافله 45 شخص نتحدث عن 47 حافله تم
تخصيصها لهؤلاء الرعايه لنقل من مساكنهم
بعد ان تم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر
الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه نشاهد الحافلات
المكيفه سوف يرافقهم عدد من الموظفين
السعوديين في عدم القطاعات الحكوميه
للتاكد من وصولهم الى مقرات سكنهم وانهاء
اجراءات عمليه التسكين وكذلك وجودهم داخل
هذه الفنادق حتى يتم تلبيه كافه
الاحتياجات الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه اثناء
مده اقامتهم هناك في المشاكل المتوقع في
ظرف 48 ساعه سوف يتم انها كافه الاجراءات
الخاصه بالمواطنين الاجانب حتى يستعدون
للسفر الى بلدانهم بعد تلبيه وتسهيل كافه
احتياجاتهم اقامه تمرير العامه للجوازات
بمنحه التاشيره استثنائيه لمده شهر لهؤلاء
الرعايه حتى ياخذون قسطا من الراحه ومن ثم
بعد ذلك يتم البث في اجراءاتهم بشكل مباشر
وسريع ايضا في المنطقه المجاهه المقابله
تبقت على متن السفينه تبقت اعداد محدوده
جدا وقد لا تتجاوز 150 شخص بعد دمه بعد ثم
نقل اعداد كبيره منها الرعايه لمقرات
السكن وانهاء اجراب اجراتهم في ظرف الساعه
واحده اخذت عمليه الانزال من هذه السفينه
لعشرين مواطن سعودي و 1866 مواطن اجنبي
ثلاث الساعات فقط وسط ممرا شرفي وسط
استقبال من قبل السفراء الاجانب
والقناصل هنا بالسفارات بالاجنبيه بجده
لاستكمال الاوراق الثبوتيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
وانهاء كافه اجراءاتهم وبعد كذلك ان تم
التاكد من سلامتهم وصحه المشاهد هذا
الحافله الان بدات بعد ان يتم امتلاع
الحافله تنتقل فورا الى مقر السكن في عبر
طرق تنظيميه دقيقه جدا وبعداد محدده لكل
حافله ومرافقين سعوديين لهذه الحافلات حتى
وصولهم الى مقرات سكر النار لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات